Alright,
now I talked to you about these fingers before and I was trying to make,
so here's,
here's kind of an overview of what I'm attempting to describe to you.
So one,
there's one category of representation that has to do with the territory that
you inhabit and that you understand that's primarily social territory and it
tends to be symbolized by masculine and usually like older male symbols.
So that's the patriarchal structure.
I really think what it is is a,
it's a personified representation of the dominance hierarchy structure.
So,
um,
if remember the lion king,
you know the pride rock thing.
So the pride rock has sort of associated with the,
with the symbols father.
And so that's,
that's that category of symbol is the symbol that I'm talking about.
So he used that,
that high place on the mountain as an indicator of dominance structure.
You saw that at the opening of the lion king movie where all the animals come,
they gather around,
they all bow before the,
the rock with the king on top of it.
And the king,
like the lion is a symbol,
generally a symbol of something like solar power because the lion is a top
Predator,
it's apex Predator and it lives in Africa under the sun.
And it has a main that sort of like a son.
And then later in the lion king will actually see this today you'll see the,
the Father Lion Mufasa,
yes,
he appears in the sky with a solar halo around him.
So,
so that's the masculine category.
And then the feminine category I told you a little about a bit about is a more
chaotic category and it's a,
it's a chaotic and plastic category out of which new forms emerge.
And then one of the categories that we haven't talked about is the category of
the individual and the individual is the hero and hero stories and is the
initiate an initiatory routines.
And so the hero is the person who is attempting to become a complete biological
and historical entity personality so that they're capable not only of,
of,
um,
adopting independent existence,
but if adopting independent existence that's productive and that's productive in
a way that's also a benefit to the community.
So it's a particular pattern of development and that that needs to be catalyzed
by human societies because in order for a society to,
to maintain its structure and for the people within it to thrive,
the developing individuals have to mature to the point where they can take care
of themselves in a way that doesn't disrupt the whole social structure.
And so that's the path.
It's a natural path for human beings.
I would say to some degree,
because we're such intensely social creatures,
but because we're also quite malleable and complex and also grounded in history
and cultural creatures,
it's also something that has to be taught both from the perspective of
invitation and explicitly.